Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again, I'm coming back at you with another
understating your DNA video to help you understand your 23AB and the presentation that we
give back your SNP report or your genetic report, which is a report of all the genetic defects
or variants that you may or may not have based upon your 23AB analysis. So this presentation
we are going to go over methylation and how that methylation that folate cycle affects
your body and the steps that we're going to be looking at it there and in that methylation
folate cycle. So this pre-assumes that you've already done your 23AB, if you haven't, go
ahead and go on 23AB.com and order that, that's separate from this, you have to order that directly
from their lab, order the large one, the 199 one, that's the current price of my change when
you're listening to this but don't get there less expensive one because we need all the genetic
steps that we can get to give you the best picture. Does that make sense? So methylation
is something you hear about a lot. MTHFR is maybe some letters that you've heard, you see
Facebook pages on MTHFR. MTHFR is stands for Bethel Tetrahydrofolate Reductase which
is a gene that makes methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase enzyme to break down 5, 10 methylene
tetrahydrofolate into 5 methyl tetrahydrofolate. That's very confusing, don't try to memorize
that but that specific gene, the MTHFR gene was one of the first that was discovered and
there's been a lot of emphasis on that, better affect a lot of people, call our office and
say, oh my gosh, my son has an MTHFR defect, this is crucial, this is very dangerous, it is
crucial, it is important to understand that but you'll see there's a lot of genes that we're
looking at and the MTHFR gene is simply one of them and to supplement or to use specific nutrition
based upon one gene in my opinion is a gross misrepresentation of genetics and it's ignorance, I believe,
and it can be extremely harmful as we'll talk about. So the methylation pathway this
folate pathway that we're looking at is this right here, thank you, Dr. Ben Lidge and
seekinghealth.org for putting together this beautiful little graphic but this graphic here
is talks about the folate cycle, folates from green leafy festival folage and folic acid.
So let's first understand the difference between folate and folic acid because this is a huge
misconception in our nutritional picture. So we have occasionally, we have people bring in a
supplement that says, you know, their question is, is this a really good supplement to take and you look
at the supplement and it has folic acid as one of the ingredients. What is folic acid? I thought
folic acid was really good for you. I thought pregnant women need folic acid, it's really important that
they get folic acid because it prevents neural tube defects in babies with such a genetic defect.
Folic acid by definition is synthetic folate, synthetic folate. So the main source of folate in a
person's diet is foliage, green leafy vegetables. However, grains also have folate in it.
And at the turn of the last century, the early 1900s, the 1920s, 30s, 40s, that was the onset of
the use of refined flour. And refined flour takes off the outer hull of the wheat, the germ of the wheat,
and that's where folate is found in grains. So the average American diet at that time was
mainly white bread biscuits, white flour. Green leafy vegetables was not a typical American diet
at the time. So the women that were pregnant were deficient in folate and a deficiency in folate
could cause a neural tube defect. Well, that was discovered that this deficiency in folate caused
neural tube defects. So instead of encouraging people to eat foliage, to eat salads, to go back to
whole wheat instead of white flour, they synthesized folate in the laboratory and called it folic acid.
So folic acid is synthesized folate. Though like so many other synthetic nutrients, they don't work
the same in the body. Matter of fact, it's hypothesized that folic acid, synthetic folate,
since it's in so many things and it's put in so many in your cereals now, it's in so many vitamins,
it's in predatol vitamins, it's theorized that it's actually the synthetic folate, the synthetic
folic acid, that is the cause of the rise of this MTHFR defect, which is significant in a person's
health. So this is the MTHFR defect like most of the defects in the genes are epigenetic defects,
that means the environment to the controlled effects on your genes, and the environmental
effect on the MTHFR gene, it is believed, is the increase use of synthetic folic acid. So with
the advent of folic acid, it actually causes an MTHFR defect, and the MTHFR defect causes a whole
bunch of possible scenarios in a person's health. The decrease ability to
methylate is the key piece, because you're not making methyl tetrahedral folate as well,
and that affects your ability to detoxify especially large chemicals like vaccinations.
So a child with an MTHFR defect in my opinion should not be vaccinated, because they can't detoxify
very well, plus you look at the pond pathways or the site of growth p450 pathways or the net pathways.
If they have defects in those pathways, it, in my opinion, it is, is abuse to vaccinate a child,
because you are greatly increasing the risk of brain issues and liver issues, because they won't be
able to detoxify the adjuvugs in the vaccination. So it is with exposure to other chemicals too.
Follow me? So you do not ever want to take a supplement that says folic acid and nothing else.
If it just says folic acid, it's made with synthetic folic acid. Some supplements, because the term
folic acid has been so prevalent, will say folic acid in a parenthesis as folate. Then that's fine.
Or they'll say folic acid parenthesis as methyl tetrahydrofolate. That's fine then, okay?
So they're using the right form of folate. That's how you could tell there's little hints when you look
at supplements. There's little hints whether they care or not. So how do they calculate the minerals?
You could tell if they care or not. What type of folate are they using? You could tell if they care
or not. What type of B12 are they using? You could tell if they care or not. Because there is like
500 articles published on this stuff. I mean, it's not that it's not known. It's just that
synthetic folic acid is a whole lot cheaper than using a good folate. So when you're
governing, okay, we saved 12 cents, a bottle of supplements here, and you quaint that out to how many
bottles and supplements that we're going to sell over the course of the year. That's $2 million, and you
covered your decision based upon your income, you're going to make bad decisions, okay? So knowing some
of these things is helpful. That's why I tell you this. Don't ever, ever, ever, ever, ever consume
folic acid. Now, I say that a little tongue in cheek because you can't, there's so many things that
have folic acid in it like enriched flour. So if you're going to go eat a donut somewhere at a store,
okay? Well, you shouldn't probably do that anyhow, but let's say if you did, it's got some,
it's got synthetic folic acid in it because they used enriched white flour for that donut.
So there's your going to consume some folic acid. You certainly don't want to buy a supplement.
It pays for a supplement that is using folic acid. So additionally, for me, if I look at anybody's
supplements, you can easily look at your own supplements. If you see folic acid, it doesn't say
as something else that you shouldn't be consuming that supplement, nor should anybody else, nor should
your dog. So side note to there, but an important side note. Folic pathway is super important because the
end point to the folic pathway is to actually make methyl tetrahedral folate, which is your
methyl group dotator that feeds into the botanian cycle and feeds into the biopteran cycle
to produce SAME, which is your main methyl transfer group for your whole body, which turns,
what does that mean? Well, that turns genes on and off. So it's really, really super important.
And it feeds into the biopteran pathway that ends up making all your neurotransmitters.
So this is an important pathway. We don't want to put too much emphasis on any one given gene. So
what a patient calls, or a potential patient, it says, oh my gosh, little Jimmy's got an MTHFR
defect. He's going to die. Okay, little Jimmy's not going to die. But you have to know some things and
we need to support some things and we need to look at the whole big picture. It's not just about
one gene, okay? It never is. It's never just about one thing. It's looking at the big picture. So
calm down. Let's do this right. Does that make sense? So look at it in this picture.
It's in this picture right here. Each one of these bubbles. So the first, the top says, reduce folates
and folic acid goes on to through these three genes, the FOLR1, FOLR2 and these other genes.
All these gene bubbles are a family of genes. Sometimes there's just one gene in that gene family.
And sometimes there's 25. So it's bigger than just one gene step. That's why I really recommend
that you get the whole 23andMe done. So we could look at all these and not just go and run a genetic
test on the MTHFR, okay? That doesn't give you a real good picture. So hopefully look at these
videos and stuff. You're getting that that just for me a little bit. So when we look at your
personalized genetic report under the MTHFR heading the folate pathway, you're going to see this one.
First, these three. First, Jesus. FOLR1, two and three.
This person, pretty good. A single allele defect just done one of them. Pretty good. That's really,
they have, don't have a problem, converting folate to the next
compound in the pathway, which is dehydroxy folate, reduct folate.
So no real big problem here. If a person has defects there, we want to deal with that. We want
to support that. But the next pathway is the DHFR gene. There's five in that family.
This person has one double allele defect on one of those genes. Not real bad. So pretty good.
It's not uncommon for us to see, especially like chronic Lyme patients, to have defects in all five
of these. This is a very important gene. In fact, this one might be, in my book, even a little bit
more important than the MTHFR gene. And so commonly overlooked, not even looked at. So this gene needs
to be supported if there's a lot of defects in there. So again, the big picture of the pathway down
at the bottom of that red arrow is this MTHFR gene, which maybe too much emphasis put on that one.
That gene has some in its family. And those are the genes that you're going to look at in the
box on the right of your screen there. The most research devolid genes is that one,
the bottom one of those five, the MTHFR C677T, and this person has a one single allele defect there.
Because there's so much research on this gene. A single allele defect has been determined that
average person with a single allele defect is going to have about a 35% reduction of the function of
that gene. Now this C677T typically drives the MTHFR pathway, which we're going to talk about in the
next presentation. That's the pathway that you really put out SAME. That's where you're going to
really make your MTHFR group. The 12.98, the one right above it, where this person doesn't have a
defect at all, Bailey pushes the biopterate pathway. But there's multiple genes in this pathway. So we
want to look at all of them. So again, the emphasis of the folate and the methylation pathway is to look
at the big picture. It's not just what gene. So hopefully that helps you understand. When you get
your report, you're going to see, many times I don't support this pathway first. We want to go slow,
and this is what we want to support. Maybe a little bit down a few months. That's a common
approach that we want to take. Versus some other doctors will, oh, you got an MTHFR defect,
we got to get you a methyl tetrahedral folate. I think that's a mistake because that will really
push the biopterate pathway quite quickly. If you have defects there, you're going to subemotional
oh person, subemotional swings because of that. You have to be careful of that.
Again, if you're watching this video, you haven't seen any of the other ones. To become a full patient,
you want to follow the full steps that we want to just differentiate between that. And understand
the 23andMe agreements and what you're receiving with this. We want to help as many people as we
possibly can. And I know by making it kind of automated like this and making videos, I'm hoping
that we're going to be able to help a lot more people. Spread the news about what we're trying to do.
I don't care if you share these videos. I don't care if you let other people see them.
They didn't pay for it. I don't care. Just give away our information. I encourage you to go on
our website, download our books as well. They could be extremely helpful. So thank you very much.
This is the kind of report you're going to get back. And don't be surprised just because you
haven't emptied the far defect that I'm not suggesting we start by supporting that right away.
The other genes are sometimes more important to support and making sure those pathways are clear
before you start giving methyl groups. But that's my opinion and because I've done the wrong way too.
So we want only the best for you. All right, you're going to look at the other videos if those are
issues for you too. And I wish you the best. Bye-bye.